because what he did was illegal he
murdered those children absolutely
first-degree murder the problem is
exactly the point that Kirsten powers
made the point of if you think that's
disgusting what he did if you think it's
disgusting
well then why is it that you don't think
it's disgusting when it happens inside
the woman because by the way it's
completely legal what he did if he had
done it in the womb completely basically
completely legal back with our lovely
guest and McElhenney
okay I have to say it in the prejudice
in a stereotypical Irish way because
otherwise I can't say it very well with
my mealy-mouthed Canadian / Midwestern
accent so we were talking about science
okay before we go into the next segment
science is not governed by consensus
it's governed by truth and put that on a
bumper sticker you've done obviously
frack nation now you're going on to this
you know Gosnell movie it's correct me
if i'm wrong the biggest indiegogo
funding campaign of all time for an
independent film it broke yeah it broke
all their records at the time for an
independent film absolutely and
certainly yeah and and it broke all
records for a non-celebrity led film
everywhere so yeah no it was a great
response what and yeah it's just amazing
because the story is is is is you know
and words really fail to describe what
Kermit Gosnell did I mean language
really starts to fail and it's really
interesting as I've worked on it and I'm
actually writing a book about it as well
and as I've worked on it the only
comparison that works for me at all
is Auschwitz mm-hmm it's the only thing
the Holocaust is all I can compare it to
because the lek because humanity you
know what one thing that was said in
Auschwitz that I think is amazing if
somebody said um where was God in
Auschwitz and a rabbi said it's the
wrong question the question is where was
humanity and I found that really helpful
with Gosnell because dealing with the
people all of the people that knew what
was going on doctors nurses people in
beautiful offices in Harrisburg and
unbelievable numbers of people knew and
did nothing and you have to ask yourself
where was humanity what how low can
people go and the scenes that happened
on a daily basis in his clinic a
are nothing anyone has ever seen in a
horror movie can compare I mean today I
was just reading Steve masse up with one
of the doctors there he had to fake
doctors who worked with him I only know
Neil & Steve massive but Steve myself is
in the category of his own he had done
in medical school training in the West
Indies was unable to get a residency he
worked in a restaurant or in a bar
excuse me in a bar and then accidentally
met Gosnell and got a job
his testimony I have never read anything
like the testimony he gave on the stand
Gosnell never defended himself and he
never stood he never took the stand he
never could they never called any
witnesses but Steve massif was
understand and he said he ran he ran
around with scissors he says that he ran
because there were just so many of them
so many of these fetuses that were
Alliance these babies that were alive
and he ran with a scissors and he said
the walls
he said the walls he said - well the
walls the blood flowed down the walls he
said that under oath under pain of
perjury that's what he said and you read
it and you think well I read it and
every day I read it and I have to leave
the computer and I have to walk out on
the beach because I'm thinking because
it's chilling to think that humanity can
get that loan who are these people and
there were eight other people working in
there these women these collection of
women that Gosnell found to do this and
they were all doing it they all did it
there was babies arriving in toilets
swimming for their lives swimming and
I'm trying to in the book that I'm
writing I'm trying to give every baby
that I can a story to try to tell the
little story they had because they
really did live you know and they tried
in their own way to make a statement and
I and I'm I want to chronicle the
statements baby boy a the one that
anyone's listening right now can look up
and look at his photograph that
beautiful boy if you put into google be
a baby boy a and Gosnell you'll see that
baby born it's 30 weeks and three days
and he curled himself up and Kareem
across who took to the stand they said
to her can you stand up can you show
everyone and she she stood up and she
called herself in her body and that's
what this little boy tried to do to try
to protect himself
they had a neonatologist understand they
asked a neonatologist to explain what
it's like to be born that age and he
said preemies they're they're really
cold they're really cold and ones that
won't survive in hospitals you know
they're if they were born and they
weren't going to survive in a hospital
that they have to they warm that they
keep them warm and and they hold them
and they dim the lights because they
find the lights really hard they find
the lights very hard on themselves so
you know so these children were born in
life most of them were viable and they
were thrown into Tupperware containers
and empty milk cartons and they curled
themselves this little boy you know and
and people just you know people were
walking by you know people were there
and one woman I interviewed recently who
had an abortion there
she said the screams were blood-curdling
she said why did no one why did no one
report it she said the room she was in
the window was open and she said she
woke up during the procedure and her
screams were blood-curdling and I'm
thinking you know it's that kind it's
that horrific it's that horrific and
it's like lots of people knew 17 years
and no one inspected it the Department
of Health should all be sacked yesterday
right for allowing that to happen on
their watch who are these people and you
say that and your husband says that and
you're the ones who are hateful
an auntie woman and that's one of the
saddest
that's one of the saddest stories ever I
mean it's one of the most touching
stories ever heard night and then when
you see the fallout of it just today we
saw this quote from Elizabeth Warren
saying the government should have any
involvement to Rand Paul saying well
what do you say what do you say mr. Paul
I say government shouldn't have anything
to do with it at any point your move as
though it something to be proud of and
by the way I was just talking with my
producer here who's um you know we've
talked about this you're not necessarily
very religious person you mentioned that
you weren't really big on the abortion
issue before this this is what
transitions for you well my producer
here is a Christian and pro-life
and when I told him about the you know
Barack Obama situation in Illinois
basically was faced with a bill in
Illinois where babies like this were
surviving abortions and being thrown
in basically garbage bins alive and I
think every single person in the state
legislature said okay we have to pick
these babies including Democrats the
only person who said no was Barack Obama
his justification was there was already
a law in the books well if that's the
case this this never and even even
needed to come to the floor
so obviously the laws weren't working
and also he could have just voted
president like he did on hundreds of
other opportunities but and this one he
was passionate enough to say no these
babies surviving abortions do not
deserve to be saved and that's where I
say you know most people I believe are
ideologue never chalk up to evil what
you can probably chalk up to
incompetence but this is one of those
situations where even if you don't
believe it's a life in the womb it's
very clear at this point that it is and
people who still line up with the mom
can do whatever they want
I say that's as close to evil as you can
get yeah yeah I mean it's it's it's
another it's it's yeah it certainly made
me start to think about the nature of
good and evil and and where does where
does evil come from and all of that I
mean it does bring up all those issues
but I for me it's almost like the the
people at the people who had had it they
all the advantages in life in other
people with the beautiful jobs in
Harrisburg the doctors in hospitals I
mean by the way there were lots of
heroes by the way lots of heroes who
were going to be very much to the
forefront in our film sure but all these
other people who were paid to protect
the citizens of the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania and whose shirt those
jerseys and moved paper around and were
filing papers and moving papers and
putting faxes here and passing things on
to their superior and when they were
spoken to but a grand jury said things
like well it was you know it wasn't my
job and I gave it to Jim and Jim gave it
to John and John you give it to the
lawyers and you're listening to them and
at one point one person in the grand
jury and Pescatore Joanne Pescatore said
it said to one of these awful people
what people died they're like Sammy
Kershaw died there kind of me I'm kind
of Maya Munger died there and she went
and she literally did this
the woman understands she went people
died just shrugged
people died you know yeah she might not
feel the same with a relative of her own
you know but their their lack of
humanity which is breath too it's just
breathtaking
and we just feel that this is why this
the movie is so important and why anyone
who's out there that's listening to us
just give us one dollar
we have 27,000 people have given us
money for this film right I would like
it to be a hundred thousand sure because
it'll make a big difference with
distributors but also it's like well
that's important to know yeah ordinary
for our listeners there it's very
important to note that this isn't just
is it over it's over two million dollars
that you've raised yes but it comes from
numbers comes with twenty seven thousand
people twenty seven thousand people and
I know for liberals who can't do math
like with the the memories pizza they
tried to say it was thirty thousand no
the math actually averaged out it was
about twenty-eight dollars on average
per donation here I don't know what the
average is but for again for liberal
math let's just make sure you understand
here that means small donations people
care about this before we go that's we
have W back-end where can people go to
most effectively fund this yeah they
just go to Gosnell movie.com go to
ghazal movie.com and just give a dollar
give a dollar and tell us that you know
that you think this matters it might I
cannot tell you how much this story
matters a great deal there is so many
issues that need that have yet to be
resolved where the media were the
complete complete shirking of
responsibility by the media but the
shirking of responsibility by so many
government agencies is is it and no one
has you know no one's been brought to
book I mean there hasn't been a huge
inquiry in Pennsylvania to prevent it
from happening again I think I mean in
my opinion is entirely opinion I think
the reason for that is that same reason
the woman gave the shoulder shrug I
think this is a physical manifestation
of what many people already know happens
inside the womb already know happens
with abortion a lot of those people if
you really pin them down they understood
the science they would acknowledge it's
a life and yeah but it's an inconvenient
life I think this is just a more
clear-cut hey it's undeniable and even
then they're going it's still not enough
to me I think I think the real problem
with our story and with the film is that
it makes people confront abortion right
because what he did was illegal he
murdered those children absolutely
first-degree murder the problem is
exactly the point that Kirsten powers
made the
point off if you think that's disgusting
what he did if you think it's disgusting
well then play is that that you don't
think it's disgusting when it happens
inside the woman because by the way it's
completely legal what he did if he had
done it in the room completely basically
completely legal and in some parts of
America in some parts of America you can
basically have an abortion right up till
the day of your delivery and that's the
law in America very few countries can
compare with that and by the way Europe
which I have a lot of bad things to say
about isn't even anywhere close to the
laws that you have here 27 24 weeks in
Pennsylvania live in 24 weeks I remember
when when the two prosecutors got this
case they these two women they let both
mothers they looked at each other and
said 24 weeks that's six months and I
mean everyone knew who's listening six
months I mean you're super pregnant at
six months and the idea that you would
keep that you are allowed by law to
legally kill that baby is quite
extraordinary at six months my mom can
tell you between my brother and I I was
kicking at six I was at almost born at
six months prematurely and my brother
almost killed my mom when he was born
and then I almost died you know whatever
pills they had to put my mom on I was
trying to get out she was going I could
sense
Stephen was angsty he was go go go
Jordan was relaxed and she could tell
this before six months I mean that's
listen we won't get this is too deep but
those are the spiritual truths that I
believe to be self-evident that every
hair was fearfully and wonderfully
created on her head and that that's a
life the second I mean that that's
growing in the womb but regardless even
just from a purely anecdotal perspective
all mothers will tell you by six months
they have one connection with their baby
so it was what I what I think do we have
time for okay let's let's give you one
more minute because the thing that I
think is extraordinary is a lot of the
people who are in favor of all these
laws we're a favor of no limits on
abortion are the same people who when
they have decided a baby themselves are
playing Mozart
I know people myself who think abortion
is a great idea they read Dickens they
read Dickens to their unborn baby now
I'm thinking well hang on how does that
work but if by the way I'm all in favor
of the Dickens at any age it's all good
I used to teach literature I think it's
great and I think the Mozart's a great
idea but you can't have both
I don't think it's okay that you need to
have Mozart played to your baby and that
it's okay that some work that
so that that baby has that humanity that
will really love that music will love
all those stories being told and yet on
the other hand you're holding the same
opinion that it's okay
to do to cut the inside of that head of
that baby inside the woman and suck out
its brains with a vacuum cleaner you
know I mean and people I think it's one
of the things we're going to do with the
film I think we I don't think it's ever
being done in a movie before we're gonna
put on the stand because it happened in
the trial an abortion doctor to explain
how it's done if people should know
absolutely you are right and
little-known fact Joe Biden's mom played
Beastie Boys while he was in the womb
and that's why party so I'm sorry I was
too it's too uncomfortable for me we got
to serious but you're absolutely right
and thank you so much we have to have
you back on the show Gosnell movie.com
if you're listening to rest really go
type it in if you're watching online we
will put the link in the description god
no movie.com
and thank you so much we have to have
you back this video subscribe by
clicking my face or click this video
next to me it's playing right now in a
box how do we do that that's the magic
of the Internet is it still playing
still playing I don't want to look at it
it's still playing isn't it